SeaWorld recently announced that in a
cost-cutting move they're gonna be
laying off up to 350 employees that's a
lot of people out of work 50 I saw that
same story and I hope you don't mind cuz
I mean I know that company's been
through a lot and and I wanted to help
so I went ahead and I hired two
unemployed SeaWorld people for our show
wait a minute no I'm wait a minute no
[Applause]
you did what well I mean they were out
of a job then you I don't care if they
were out of a job Annie you do not have
the authority ladies and gentlemen
welcome to a world of wonder
[Applause]
and welcome to Conan world
behold the majesty in the mystery of the
Conan a creature with genetic ties to
both the cockatoo and the electric eel
you know I'm not a creature not a
creature the Commons usually don't grow
this large in captivity but as you can
see this is a pretty tall female oh I'm
not a female ok she's getting a little
bit testy right now I know it'll cheer
her up
ok here we go
[Applause]
wait a minute knock it off wire what
what the hell was that
I will not be clicked that yeah and why
are those people wearing Poncho's in the
front row cuz they're in the splash zone
what do you mean what are you talking
about splat zone
if the coning gets agitated enough she
will excrete flop sweat that's know
everyone
[Applause]
Wow a major splash from Makonnen we only
see those when the females are ready to
mate what are you talking about bring
out the hi ladies and gentleman from the
crystal blue waters of Costa Rica
please welcome Sebastian
[Applause]
now on the other hand is a male Conan
yeah this is not happening
there's no
[Applause]
you